A couple years back, 99 PI producer Emmett Fitzgerald brought us a beautiful story about Peat Bongs. Peat is essential for biodiversity and for the climate. It is really, really good at storing carbon. But like a lot of things that we cover on the show, Peat often goes unnoticed, in part because it is literally out of sight underground. We've noticed Peat and carbon sequestration more and more in the news lately.
几年前，99 PI 的制作人埃mett · 菲茨杰拉德给我们带来了一个关于泥炭沼泽的美妙故事。泥炭对生物多样性和气候至关重要。它在储存碳方面真的非常非常厉害。但就像我们在节目中报道的许多事情一样，泥炭经常被忽视，部分原因是因为它字面上就藏在地表以下看不见的地方。最近我们在新闻中越来越多地注意到泥炭和碳封存。
Journalists have been brilliantly covering stories about the tree planting movement, private ownership of Scotland's bogs, and the threat to Pete in the Congo basin. Couple that with even more extreme weather happening in more places, and we thought it would be a good idea to repeat this story. Did you really think I could resist that?
记者们一直在精彩地报道关于植树运动、苏格兰沼泽的私有化以及刚果盆地泥炭所面临威胁的故事。再加上更多地方发生着更加极端的天气，我们觉得重温这个故事会是个好主意。你真的以为我能抗拒这个吗？
I mean, I'm only human. Anyway, enjoy. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. As we wrote this script, wildfires were ripping through northern California, burning millions of acres and filling our beautiful city with smoke. At the same time, across the country, a massive tropical storm bore down on the Gulf Coast, and Phoenix, Arizona, recorded its 50th day of the year above 110 degrees. We know that these stories are connected to a bigger story and honestly trying to keep on top of all the bad climate news can be unbearably depressing.
我的意思是，我只是个凡人。不管怎样，请欣赏。这里是 99%无形。我是罗马 · 马斯。当我们写下这段解说词时，野火正肆虐北加州，烧毁了数百万英亩的土地，并将我们美丽的城市填满浓烟。与此同时，大洋彼岸，一场巨大的热带风暴正压向墨西哥湾沿岸，而亚利桑那州的菲尼克斯则记录了今年第 50 个气温超过 110 华氏度的日子。我们知道这些报道与一个更大的故事息息相关，说实话，试图跟进所有关于气候的坏消息可能会令人沮丧到难以承受。
They're the kind of headlines that make you want to just not click. And so when it seems like there's a piece of genuinely good environmental news, I always smash that link. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. Solar power prices at an all-time low. Endangered tigers making a comeback. Exxon mobile doing so poorly gets taken off the Dow Jones. And one morning in the summer of 2019 right after the warmest June in history of June,
这些头条新闻会让你只想不去点击。因此，当似乎出现了一条真正的好环境新闻时，我总是会狂点那个链接。这是制作人埃mett · 菲茨杰拉德。太阳能价格创下历史新低。濒危的老虎卷土重来。埃克森美孚表现如此糟糕，以至于被从道琼斯指数中剔除。在 2019 年夏天的一个早晨，就在有记录以来最热的六月刚过去之后，
I got a surprise dopamine hit when I saw this headline. Tree planting has mind-blowing potential to tackle climate crisis. Now, to be perfectly clear, the most mind-blowing thing we could do to tackle the climate crisis is to stop burning fossil fuels. But there are also ways that we can soak up some of the CO2 that we've already put into the atmosphere.
当我看到这个标题时，我获得了意外的多巴胺冲击。植树具有应对气候危机的惊人潜力。现在，为了把话说清楚，我们为应对气候危机能做的最惊人的事就是停止燃烧化石燃料。但也有一些方法可以让我们吸收一些已经排放到大气中的二氧化碳。
We're developing machines to do this, but trees and other plants actually do it naturally. They take carbon from the atmosphere and store it in their leaves and branches and trunks. And so some scientists in Switzerland tried to calculate how much carbon could be removed if we planted as many trees as possible all around the world. They published a paper in the journal Nature arguing that if humans planted a trillion trees, it could remove one third of all the CO2. We had put up there in the first place.
我们正在研发能做到这一点的机器，但树木和其他植物实际上是自然做到这一点的。它们从大气中吸收碳，并将其储存在叶子、枝条和树干中。因此，瑞士的一些科学家试图计算出，如果我们尽可能多地在世界各地种树，可以清除多少碳。他们在《自然》杂志上发表了一篇论文，论证说如果人类种下一万亿棵树，就可以清除所有人排放到大气中的二氧化碳的三分之一。
It was a dramatic finding that led to a lot of dramatic headlines. And the way the paper was being described, you would think the trees were some kind of climate change panacea that they were the key to fixing global warming. And in the months that followed it felt like the tree planting theory was being aggressively put into practice. Plant a tree to fight the effects of fossil fuels. We start in Ethiopia where a huge campaign has been launched to plant more than four billion trees this summer. Volunteers in India planted more than 66 million trees in just 12 hours in a record breaking.
这是一个戏剧性的发现，引发了许多戏剧性的头条新闻。根据对这篇论文的描述，你会以为树木是某种应对气候变化的灵丹妙药，是解决全球变暖的关键。在随后的几个月里，植树理论似乎被积极地付诸实践。种树来对抗化石燃料的影响。我们从埃塞俄比亚开始，那里今年夏天发起了一场种植超过四十亿棵树的巨大运动。印度的志愿者在短短 12 小时内打破记录种植了超过 6600 万棵树。
There's even a tree planting and them. Eventually, the tree planting gospel found the unlikliest of champions. President Donald Trump expressed his love of tree planting at the world economic forum, and then Trump, the man who pulled the U.S. out of the Paris climate treaty, signed on to something called the Trillion Trees Initiative. On Earth Day, President Trump gathered the press on the White House lawn to watch him plant a tree of his own. As a sign of our dedication in a few moments, the first lady and I will plant a maple tree right here on the south lawn of the White House and wherever the tree is, where is this tree now?
甚至还有一个植树节。最终，植树的福音找到了最不可能的支持者。唐纳德 · 特朗普总统在世界经济论坛上表达了他对植树的热爱，接着特朗普——这位将美国拉出《巴黎气候协定》的人——签署了一项名为“一万亿棵树倡议”的计划。在地球日，特朗普总统召集记者来到白宫草坪，观看他亲手种下一棵树。作为我们奉献精神的象征，一会儿，第一夫人和我就将在白宫南草坪这里种下一棵枫树，不管这棵树在哪，这棵树现在在哪？
That's a beautiful street trunk. That's a triple A tree. The triple A tree was already in the ground, but the president, the first lady, members of cabinet, picked up their golden shovels and threw some dirt in the hole. Okay, I'm not a good expert at everything. Now don't get me wrong, I don't have anything against trees. I, in fact, I love trees, just as much as the next outdoorsy guy from Vermont. But I've also been reporting on climate change long enough to know that there are no silver bullets.
那是一根漂亮的树干。这是一棵 AAA 级树。AAA 级的树已经种在土里了，但总统、第一夫人、内阁成员们拿起他们的金铲子，往洞里铲了一些泥土。好吧，我并不是对所有事情都很擅长。现在别误会我，我并不反对树。事实上，我喜欢树，就像来自佛蒙特州的下一个热爱户外活动的人一样。但我报道气候变化的时间也足够长，知道世上没有银弹。
And the way people were talking about tree planting felt, you know, a little simplistic. It was like, here's this enormously complicated issue, climate change. And we're just going to boil it down to a slogan, plant trees. say the earth. Well, whenever I hear that phrase, all that discourse, my stress level goes up enormously. This is Richard Lindsay, a scientist at the University of East London's Sustainability Research Institute. Everybody is saying, let's plant a million trees, let's plant a billion trees. Yes, I'm all in favor of that, but let's plant the right tree in the right place.
人们谈论植树的方式，你知道的，感觉有点过于简单化了。这就好像，气候变化是一个极其复杂的问题。而我们却把它浓缩成了一个口号，种树。拯救地球。好吧，每当我听到那个短语，听到所有这些讨论，我的压力水平就会急剧上升。这是理查德 · 林赛，伦敦东区大学可持续发展研究所的科学家。每个人都在说，让我们种一百万棵树，让我们种十亿棵树。是的，我完全赞成这一点，但让我们在对的地方种对的树。
And Richard has personal experience watching a lot of trees get planted in the wrong place. Back in the 1980s, he saw firsthand the impacts of a controversial tree planting scheme in Scotland that ended up threatening one of the most special ecosystems in the world. The trees weren't being planted to fight climate change. I want to be really clear about that.
理查德亲身经历过看到许多树被种错地方的情况。早在 20 世纪 80 年代，他就亲眼目睹了苏格兰一项备受争议的植树计划所带来的影响，该计划最终威胁到了世界上最特殊的生态系统之一。种树并不是为了对抗气候变化。这一点我想明确指出。
Very few people were talking about climate change back then. But the story of what happened in Scotland should still serve as a cautionary tale for our tree planting efforts today, because forests aren't the only ecosystems that store carbon. And so when we do plant trees, we need to be really careful about where we're planting them and what happens after they go in the ground. The British Isles used to be covered in forests, but after centuries of converting forest land to agriculture, the iconic British woodland was largely a thing of the past. By the 20th century, Great Britain was importing wood because it didn't have enough of its own. And so,
那时很少有人谈论气候变化。但苏格兰发生的事情仍然应该给我们今天的植树努力敲响警钟，因为森林并不是唯一储存碳的生态系统。因此，当我们确实种树时，我们需要非常小心我们在哪里种树以及它们入土之后会发生什么。不列颠群岛过去曾被森林覆盖，但在几个世纪将林地转变为农业用地后，标志性的英国林地已在很大程度上成为了过去式。到了 20 世纪，大英国协因自身木材不足而不得不进口木材。因此，
in the 1980s, the government started using tax breaks to encourage private citizens to fund tree planting efforts around the country. The goal was to boost the UK's timber supply. And it was a really good tax break, especially for the super rich. So we had people like, well, the band, Genesis, their accountants, got them involved in this. Yes, a number of sort of high profile names who all invested in this, having been convinced
在 20 世纪 80 年代，政府开始利用税收减免来鼓励普通公民资助全国各地的植树活动。目标是促进英国的木材供应。这是一个非常好的税收减免，特别是对超级富豪而言。所以我们有这样的人，比如，乐队“创世纪”，他们的会计师让他们参与了进来。是的，一些知名人士都投资了这个项目，他们被说服了
that it was a good thing because of course planting trees is a good thing. Is it not? But questions started to emerge about where exactly these trees were going to go. In order for this to work, investors needed large tracks of undeveloped, unwanted land. And there was one place that met that criteria perfectly. It was called the Flow Country. And there was one place that met that criteria perfectly. It was called the Flow Country. The Flow Country is a vast open area in far north of Scotland
认为这是一件好事，因为种树当然是一件好事。难道不是吗？但关于这些树究竟要去哪里的问题开始浮现。为了让这个计划行之有效，投资者需要大片未开发的、无人想要的土地。有一个地方完美符合这个标准。它被称为流淌之乡。有一个地方完美符合这个标准。它被称为流淌之乡。流淌之乡是苏格兰最北部一片广阔开阔的地区，
that looks almost like the Arctic Tundra. The term Tundra comes from the Finnish word Tundtree, which means beyond the tree line. And so that really tells you something about the overall landscape. It's essentially treeless. The flow country is what's called a blanket bog. It's actually the largest blanket bog in all of Europe. The best way to appreciate the landscape might be in an airplane.
看起来几乎像是北极苔原。苔原（Tundra）这个词来自芬兰语 Tundtree，意思是树木线之外。所以这确实告诉你一些关于整体地貌的信息。它基本上是没有树的。流淌之乡被称为毯式泥炭沼。它实际上是全欧洲最大的毯式泥炭沼。欣赏这片地貌最好的方式可能是在飞机上。
From the sky, it looks like a Persian rug, streaked with colorful sphagnum mosses, and dotted with little pools of water. Well, it's harder to appreciate when you're on the ground. The majority of the landscape will be this wet, boggy, soft, a really quite colorful carpet of bog mosses. So as you walk across it, it's a bit like walking across a sprung mattress, except you need rubber boots. Yeah, a soggy, a soggy mattress.
从空中看，它就像一块波斯地毯，点缀着色彩斑斓的泥炭藓，并星罗棋布地点缀着小水洼。好吧，当你身处地面时，就很难去欣赏它了。大部分的地貌都是这种湿润、泥泞、松软、色彩相当丰富的泥炭藓地毯。所以当你走在上面时，有点像走在弹簧床垫上，除了你需要穿雨靴。是的，一个湿漉漉的，湿漉漉的床垫。
Sogy is a very good word for it. Yes. There's a saying in Scotland that summer is the best day of the year. It's called in damp and gets an enormous amount of rainfall. But otherwise, it's perfect. It truly is one of my favorite places on Earth. Yeah, and beautiful Scotland's terrible weather actually creates the perfect conditions for an incredible substance to form. It's called Pete, and it's what the flow country is made of.
湿漉漉的是形容它的一个非常好的词。是的。苏格兰流传着这样一句话，夏天是一年中最美好的一天。它被称为潮湿，降雨量巨大。除此之外，它堪称完美。它确实是我在地球上最喜欢的地方之一。是的，而且苏格兰糟糕透顶的天气实际上为一种令人惊叹的物质的形成创造了完美条件。它被称为泥炭，流淌之乡就是由它组成的。
The land is so saturated, there's very little oxygen, and it's really hard for plant matter to break down. And so over thousands and thousands of years, this partially decomposed material, or peat, has been slowly accumulating. In some parts of the flow country, the peat is now more than 30 feet deep. And the amazing thing about peat from a climate perspective is that it stores a ton of carbon. I fell in love with Petland because they are these beautiful ecosystems, but they also are
这片土地如此饱和，以至于氧气极少，植物物质很难分解。因此，经过成千上万年的时间，这种部分分解的物质，即泥炭，一直在缓慢积聚。在流淌之乡的某些地方，泥炭现在有 30 多英尺深。从气候的角度来看，泥炭最神奇的地方在于它储存了大量的泥炭。我爱上了泥炭地，因为它们是美丽的生态系统，但它们也是
global powerhouses for carbon storage. This is Merit Turetski, or the Queen of Pete, as she's known on Twitter. She's the director of the Institute of Arctic and Alpine Research at UC Boulder. And she says that Petelands are like these dense underground pockets of carbon. So the amount of carbon stored in Petelands on a meter square basis is often 10 times, 15 times higher
储存碳的全球巨头。这是梅丽特 · 图雷茨基，或者正如她在推特上为人所知的那样，泥炭女王。她是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校北极和高山研究所所长。她说泥炭地就像地下密集的碳口袋。因此，以平方米为基础储存在泥炭地中的碳量通常高出 10 倍、15 倍
than that same area of land in a forest or in an agricultural setting. These are true hot spots when it comes to protecting carbon in soils and keeping that carbon out of the atmosphere. Peatlands around the world actually contain more carbon than all the worlds of vegetation combined. But back in the 80s, most people didn't know about this the worlds of vegetation combined. But back in the 80s, most people didn't know about this incredible power of peat. If anything, bogs were seen as unpleasant, scary places to be avoided.
高于森林或农业环境中的同一块土地。在保护土壤中的碳以及将这些碳隔离在大气之外方面，这些是真正的热点地区。世界上泥炭地实际储存的碳比世界上所有植被加起来还要多。但在 20 世纪 80 年代，大多数人并不知道世界上所有植被加起来的碳。但早在 80 年代，大多数人并不知道泥炭这种不可思议的力量。如果有的话，沼泽曾被视为令人不快、可怕、应该避开的地方。
In part because they were filled with dead people, ancient bog bodies that had been pickled for centuries in the anaerobic muck. Some of these bodies appear to be ritual sacrifices from the bronze and iron ages. Once those bodies were tossed into the bog, they became very efficiently preserved. Because of those same conditions that protect Pete from decomposition, the bog bodies didn't decompose. And occasionally, these eerily well-preserved corpses would surface from the bogs of northern Europe. Nathasde in Scotland, the spooky, soggy peatland, wasn't exactly a popular spot.
部分原因是因为它们里面充满了死人，即在厌氧淤泥中腌制了几个世纪的古代沼泽木乃伊。其中一些尸体似乎是青铜时代和铁器时代的祭品。一旦这些尸体被扔进沼泽，它们就会得到非常高效的保存。由于保护泥炭免于分解的相同条件，沼泽木乃伊没有分解。偶尔，这些诡异保存完好的尸体浮出北欧的沼泽。纳萨德在苏格兰，这个阴森、湿漉漉的泥炭地，并不是一个很受欢迎的地方。
The flow country was known locally by an acronym, Mamba. Famously it was called Mamba Country, Miles Miles of Buggerall. And so, in the 1980s, when the forest industry started looking for large tracks of undeveloped land to plant trees, the flow country was an obvious choice. You know, it was seen as a wasteland, so the local people had been convinced by the forest industry that this was going to bring a new economy to the area. So, you know, of course, local people were really excited. What happened next was kind of a race between the four few groups
当地人给流淌之乡起了一个缩写名，Mamba。它有个著名的绰号叫曼巴之乡，意为几英里又几英里的鸟不拉屎。因此，在 20 世纪 80 年代，当林业行业开始寻找大片未开发的土地来种树时，流淌之乡是一个显而易见的选择。你知道，它被视为不毛之地，所以当地人被林业行业说服，认为这将为该地区带来新的经济。所以，你知道的，当地人当然非常兴奋。接下来发生的事情有点像一场竞赛，一方是
who started draining the peat bogs and planting trees and conservation groups who began trying to catalog all the biodiversity in this fragile landscape before it was completely covered up. And that's where I was really sucked into the whole flow country story because essentially I was tasked with running a survey program to establish whether the flow country contained anything of importance, anything that we should be concerned about losing. Richard assembled a team of scientists. They packed up tents and camping gear, cameras, and food,
开始排干泥炭沼并种树的少数几个集团，另一方是保护组织，他们开始试图在这个脆弱的景观被完全覆盖之前，对其所有的生物多样性进行编目。这就是我真正被卷入整个流淌之乡故事的地方，因为我基本上被委派去运行一个调查项目，以确定流淌之乡是否包含任何重要事物，任何我们应该担心失去的事物。理查德组建了一支科学家团队。他们打包了帐篷和露营装备、相机和食物，
and took the train from London, over 400 miles north to the tippy top of Scotland. And right away, Richard was taken with the place. It was extraordinary, first of all, in the silence. But pretty quickly, he got acquainted with the sounds and smells of the place too. For weeks he and his team would tramp around on top of the soggy mattress, documenting all of the wildlife in the bog. Carnivorous plants, dragonflies, water beetles,
坐火车从伦敦出发，向北行驶 400 多英里，来到苏格兰的极顶。理查德立刻就被这个地方迷住了。首先，这里的寂静是非同寻常的。但很快，他也熟悉了这个地方的声音和气味。连续几周，他和他的团队在这张湿漉漉的床垫上四处跋涉，记录沼泽中的所有野生动物。食肉植物、蜻蜓、水甲虫、
loons, and golden plovers. It was tough going, but apart from the wet socks, Richard remembers these long walks fondly. Because you sort of bounce gently along, there's a sort of squish, squish underfoot, and there's the lovely scent of all the heathers and the various sort of flowery plants that wafted up around you. And in the end, Richard and his team determined that the flow-couchy wasn't a wasteland at all,
潜鸟和金鸻。这是一段艰难的旅程，但除了湿漉漉的袜子，理查德对这些长途跋涉怀有美好的回忆。因为你在上面轻轻地弹跳，脚下有一种咯吱咯吱的挤压感，而且周围飘荡着所有欧石南和各种花卉植物的可爱香味。最终，理查德和他的团队确定流淌之乡根本不是什么不毛之地，
but a thriving wetland habitat that had been underappreciated for centuries. Essentially, we found that the range of ecosystem types was like nothing, well, really, that had been described anywhere else in the world. But as all this was happening, the tree planting was already underway, and so at the same time Richard was discovering the secrets of this delicate landscape, the forestry companies were tearing it up. They plowed up the bogs, drained out all that water, and planted non-native, quick-growing
而是一个繁荣的湿地栖息地，几个世纪以来一直被低估了。本质上，我们发现生态系统类型的范围是独一无二的，嗯，实际上，这在世界上任何其他地方都没有被描述过。但正当这一切发生时，植树工作已经在进行中，因此在理查德探索这片细腻景观秘密的同时，林业公司也在将其摧毁。他们犁开沼泽，排干所有的水，并种植了外来的、速生的
conifers. Pretty soon, little patches of evergreen forest were sprouting up all across the flow country, although Richard says forest isn't really the right word. No, they're plantations. Plantations established with agricultural densities in mind. Rose and Rose have sittka spruce and lodgepole pine packed tightly together. In these dense plantations, we're terrible places for native wildlife. They quickly filled up with predators that scared off many of the birds that Richard and his team were just beginning to learn about. The petalins were turning into a tree farm.
针叶树。很快，一小片一小片的常绿森林在整个流淌之乡破土而出，尽管理查德说森林并不是正确的词。不，它们是人工林。以农业密度为理念建立的人工林。一行又一行的锡特卡云杉和扭叶松紧密地挤在一起。这些密集的种植园是本地野生动物的噩梦。它们迅速充满了吓跑许多鸟类的捕食者，而理查德和他的团队才刚刚开始了解这些鸟类。泥炭地正在变成一个树木农场。
So yeah, pretty, so destroying. As they did their work, Richard and the other scientists were called to testify in local meetings about the Forestry Project, and they had to argue that this seemingly empty, worthless landscape was actually worth protecting. And essentially, it's our equivalent of the tropical rainforest. But the forest industry didn't see it that way. I just have this general memory of being shouted at a lot for a very long time. They were banging the table and they were shouting at us and demanding to know what we thought we were doing.
所以，是的，相当，具有破坏性。在他们工作的同时，理查德和其他科学家被召集在关于林业项目的当地会议上作证，他们必须辩称这片看似空旷、毫无价值的景观实际上值得保护。本质上，这就是我们相当于热带雨林的东西。但林业行业并不这么认为。我只是有这样一种普遍的记忆，就是被大声斥责了很长时间。他们拍着桌子对我们大喊大叫，质问我们以为自己在做什么。
To reach our response was, well, we think we're doing our job. Our job was to identify important areas of the nation's wildlife heritage. And that's exactly what we were doing. Was it weird at the time to be arguing that trees were an environmental problem? Oh, that was so difficult. Yes, but, you know, it's like everything. You know, a medication is a good thing when used in the right way, in the right place,
我们的回应是，好吧，我们认为我们在做我们的工作。我们的工作是识别国家野生动物遗产中的重要区域。这正是我们在做的事情。当时争论树木是一个环境问题，这感觉奇怪吗？哦，那太难了。是的，但是，你知道，这就像所有事情一样。你知道，一种药物在以正确的方式、在正确的地方使用时是一件好事，
used in the wrong way, in the wrong place. It's a poison, and that was the tricky message that we had to try and get across. But over time, public opinion began to turn against the tree planting. A lot of that had to do with the fact that it seemed like an egregious form of tax avoidance, but the message about the Petelins was also starting to get through. The government eventually agreed to protect about half of the Petelins that Richard and
在错误的地方、以错误的方式使用它。它就是一种毒药，这就是我们必须努力传达的棘手信息。但随着时间的推移，公众舆论开始反对植树。这在很大程度上是因为这似乎是一种极端的避税形式，但关于泥炭地的消息也开始传开。政府最终同意保护理查德和他的
his team had surveyed, and then a couple months later, they completely ended the tax scheme. A colleague phoned me. He just said, it's gone. What's gone? The first-year-grand scheme, it's gone. I don't remember. I had to sit down. I was so surprised. It was a big win for the bog, and the conservationists fighting to protect it. And in the decades that followed the way people saw the flow country, really started to shift. It went from being a place people avoided to a place that people wanted to see. The largest blanket bog in all of Europe. And people were coming to visit it to see this, this amazing landscape. And all of
团队调查过的大约一半的泥炭地，然后几个月后，他们彻底结束了这项税收计划。一位同事打电话给我。他只是说，它没了。什么没了？第一年大额补助计划，没了。我不记得了。我不得不坐下来。我太惊讶了。这对沼泽以及为保护它而战的环保主义者来说是一场伟大的胜利。在随后的几十年里，人们看待流淌之乡的方式确实开始转变。它从一个人们避之不及的地方变成了一个人们想要去看看的地方。全欧洲最大的毯式泥炭沼。人们来这里参观是为了看这个，这个令人惊叹的景观。所有这些
this gradually chipped away at the idea of, this is useless wasteland. And people began to relate to it as their landscape, their precious landscape. But a lot of damage had been done. Over 150,000 acres of the flow country had been drained and planted with trees. These trees never really grew very well. They were short and stubby and not very useful as timber.
逐渐消解了“这是无用的不毛之地”这一观念。人们开始将其视为他们的景观，他们珍贵的景观。但已经造成了很大的破坏。流淌之乡超过 15 万英亩的土地被排干并种上了树。这些树从未真正长得很好。它们又矮又粗，作为木材并没有多大用处。
But the plantations pushed out native wildlife that depended on the bog and damaged the precious peat that was storing all that carbon. And the flow country wasn't the only place where this kind of thing happened. Chile, to take one example, started incentivizing tree planting around the same time as the
但人工林排挤了依赖沼泽的本地野生动物，并破坏了储存所有这些碳的珍贵泥炭。流淌之乡并不是发生这种事情的唯一地方。举个例子，智利在与英国差不多的时间开始激励植树。虽然他们确实种了很多树，但这项努力导致了生物多样性的下降，气候效益微乎其微。在加拿大艾伯塔省，他们排干了大片沼泽以便种树，同样是从 80 年代开始的。但其中大部分树木在 2016 年麦克默里堡大火中被烧毁，部分原因是曾经湿润的土地被排干变干了。
UK. And while they did plant a lot of trees, the effort led to a decline in biodiversity and negligible climate benefits. In Alberta, Canada, they drained large swaths of bog in order to plant trees, again, starting in the 80s. But most of those trees burned down in the Fort McMurray fire of 2016, in part because the once wet ground had been drained dry.
早在 20 世纪 80 年代，理查德 · 林赛和他的同事们只关心生物多样性和被低估的泥炭沼泽，但近年来，随着气候危机日益紧迫，人们越来越关注生态系统中的碳储存。科学家们正在研究海带森林和海草床中的碳动态，
Back in the 1980s, Richard Lindsay and his colleagues were only concerned about the biodiversity and the underappreciated peat bog, but in recent years as the urgency of the climate crisis grows, there's been an increased focus on carbon storage in ecosystems. Scientists are studying the carbon dynamics and kelp forests and seagrass beds, and
尤其是泥炭地因其储碳能力而受到了很多关注。你知道你已经成了主流，当亚历山大 · 鲍德温在联合国公益广告中谈论你时。泥炭地对于应对气候变化至关重要。关于泥炭地，情况是这样的。它们对地球至关重要，因为它们储存的碳实际上是世界所有森林总和的两倍，而占地面积却不到陆地表面的 3%。
petlands in particular have been getting a lot of attention for their carbon storing powers. You know you've gone mainstream when Alec Baldwin is talking about you in a PSA for the UN. Pete lands are crucial to fight climate change. And here's the thing about Pete land. They matter for the planet because they actually store twice as much carbon as all the world's forests together while covering less than 3% of the land's surface.
因此，泥炭地是地球上最高效的陆地碳汇。这是罗克珊 · 安德森。她一直在苏格兰环境研究所研究泥炭地。几十年来，她感觉自己一直在学术界的某个角落默默耕耘。她没有像我这样的记者缠着她做采访，但这种情况正在改变。我想仅今年一年，我就做了大约 15 或 20 个采访。但安德森说，说到碳储存，泥炭地仍然没有像森林那样受到关注。
So, Pete lands are the most efficient terrestrial carbon-synchland-a-planet. This is Roxanne Anderson. She's been studying Peelums for a while now at the Environmental Research Institute in Scotland. And for decades it felt like she was laboring away in some obscure corner of academia. She didn't have journalists like me bugging her for interviews, but that's changing. I think this year alone I must have given something like 15 or 20 interviews. But Anderson says that when it comes to carbon storage, peatlands still don't get the attention that forests do.
她认为这是因为泥炭地中的所有碳都在地下。我认为这是因为它看不见。这就是为什么你的播客名字引起了强烈的共鸣。如果你看一片森林，你会看到树木，你会看到植被，你会看到碳在哪里，你会看到它为什么在吸收碳。但尽管泥炭地中的碳隐藏在地下，它并没有被永远锁住。就像森林会被烧毁一样，泥炭地也会退化，会被农业或牧场吞噬。当这种情况发生时，它的大部分碳都会释放到大气中，碳汇就变成了碳源。
She thinks it's because all the carbon in a peatland is below ground. I think that it's because it's not visible. That's why the name of your podcast really resonated. If you look at a forest, you see the trees, you see the vegetation, you see where the carbon is, you see why it's taking up carbon. But even though the carbon in a peatland is hidden underground, it's not locked away forever. Just as a forest can burn down, a peatland can be degraded, can be gobbled up for agriculture or ranching. And when that happens, a lot of its carbon goes up into the atmosphere, and the carbon sink becomes a carbon source.
流淌之乡发生的就是这种情况，只不过在这个案例中，吞噬泥炭地的作物是树木。当你排干泥炭沼泽去种树时，它会释放碳。然后，随着树木生长，它们的根会影响土壤中碳的处理方式。土壤中碳的流失实际上可能超过树木吸收的碳量。因此，在泥炭上，特别是深层泥炭上种树，真的非常非常不是一个好主意。这至少会导致意想不到的后果，即释放的碳多于你通过树木获得的碳。因此，现在在流淌之乡，对气候最好的做法实际上可能是砍树。身处其中一些黑暗潮湿的人工林中会让人感到相当压抑。所以当你开始砍伐它们并再次开始开放景观时，
And that's what happened in the flow country, except in this case the crop that was gobbling up the peatland was trees. When you drain a peat bog to plant trees, it releases carbon. And then, as the trees grow, their roots impact the way the carbon in the soil is processed. And the carbon losses from the soil can actually exceed the amount of carbon that's taken up in the tree. So planting trees on peets, on deep peets, particularly, is really, really not a good idea. It's least the unintended consequences of basically losing more carbon than you can gain through the trees. of basically losing more carbon than you can gain through the trees. And so now, in the flow country, the best thing for the climate may actually be to cut trees down. It's quite claustrophobic being in some of these dark damp plantations. And so when you start taking them down and start opening up the landscape again,
在某些情况下，这实际上相当具有宣泄作用。这是保罗 · 特纳，皇家鸟类保护协会的工作人员。1995 年，RSPB 在流淌之乡购买了一个 5 万英亩的保护区，这片土地曾被大量种植树木。从那以后，他们一直在努力恢复沼泽。我们真的花了大约 25 年时间试图修复 70 年代和 80 年代对泥炭地部分地区造成的破坏。一些从事这项修复工作的承包商实际上就是当年在 80 年代排干沼泽的当地人。首先，他们砍下树木并将其运出
in some ways it's actually quite cathartic. This is Paul Turner, awarding with the Royal Society for the Protection of Birds. And in 1995, the RSPB purchased a 50,000 acre reserve in the flow country, on land that had been heavily planted with trees. Since then, they've been working to restore the bog. We've really spent sort of 25 years trying to repair damage that was done in the 70s and 80s to bits of the peatlands. Some of the contractors doing this repair work are actually the same local people who drained the bog back in the 80s. First they cut the trees down and haul
。然后至关重要的下一步是重新弄湿土壤。他们在泥炭中建造水坝，试图将地下水位恢复到正常水平，并找回那个湿漉漉的沼泽。这项工作很大一部分是用重型机械完成的，看起来并不美观。是的，你会有这样的时候，你认为实际上这是一个相当具有破坏性的过程，但当你开始看到我们 10 年、15 年前做的一些工作时，它真的会让你对你试图用它实现的目标感到相当不错。罗克珊 · 安德森研究了保罗 · 特纳和 RSPB 恢复的沼泽，
them out. Then the crucial next step is to re-wet the soil. They build dams in the peat to try to return the water table to its normal level and get that soggy bog back. A lot of this work is done with heavy machinery and it does not look pretty. And yeah, you have days where you think actually this is quite a destructive process, but when you start seeing some of the work that we did, to our 10, 15 years ago, it really makes you feel quite good about what you're trying to achieve with it. Roxanne Anderson has studied the bogs that Paul Turner and the RSPB have restored
以试图了解气候影响。所以我们发现，当你从泥炭地砍下树木并进行恢复时，最初它会释放碳，这并不奇怪，因为你在砍伐木材和其他一切方面必须对物理环境造成损害。但在几十年的恢复过程中，沼泽已经从碳源转回了碳汇。从而有效地恢复了泥炭地的这种碳效益或气候效益。但在他们做这项工作时，保罗 · 特纳不断遇到 30 年前理查德 · 林赛遇到过的问题。
to try and understand the climate impacts. So what we've found is that when you take trees down from a peatland and do the restoration, initially it releases carbon, that's not very surprising because of the kind of physical damage that you have to do in terms of cutting the words and everything else. But over the course of decades of restoration, the bogs have switched back from a carbon source to a carbon sink. So effectively returning this kind of carbon benefit or climate benefits of beetlands. But as they do this work, Paul Turner keeps running into the same problem that Richard
很难向人们解释为什么树木在这个非常具体的情况下对生态系统有害。有很多人并不真正理解我们为什么要砍树。这是因为肯定种树是最好的事情。正如我之前提到的，在正确的地方种树绝对是一件非常好的事情。保罗并不反树。
Lindsay did 30 years ago. It's hard to explain to people why trees, in this very specific situation, are bad for the ecosystem. There are a lot of people that don't really understand why we are cutting trees down. It's because surely planting trees is the best thing to do. And as I mentioned before, planting trees in the right place is definitely a really good thing to do. And as I mentioned before, planting trees in the right place is definitely a really good thing to do. Paul is not anti-tree.
事实上，RSPB 实际上还在苏格兰凯恩戈姆山脉帮助管理另一片土地，他们在那里积极种树，以努力恢复森林并封存碳。苏格兰政府正在帮助资助这两项努力。苏格兰的目标是在 2030 年之前恢复超过 60万英亩的泥炭沼泽。
In fact, the RSPP actually helps manage another piece of land in Scotland in the Karingoran Mountains, where they are actively planting trees in an effort to restore the forest and sequester carbon. And the Scottish Government is helping fund both of these efforts. Scotland has a goal of restoring over 600,000 acres of peatbock by 2030.
与此同时，他们希望每年种植 3万英亩的新林。他们在某个地方种树，就像他们在另一个地方砍树一样。这是要明白并非所有栖息地都是平等的，并非所有栖息地都应该有树，当我们谈论缓解气候变化时，没有一个答案适用于每个问题。森林很好，但它们并非在任何地方都好。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢森林。但我同样喜欢其他生态系统。这是一位名叫福雷斯特的森林科学家，福雷斯特 · 弗莱施曼。
And at the same time, they want to plant 30,000 acres of new forest each year. They are planting trees in one place just as they're cutting trees down in another. It's understanding that not all habitats are equal, that not all habitats should have trees on them, and that when we're talking about climate change mitigation, that one answer doesn't apply to every problem. Forests are great, but they aren't great everywhere. Yeah, I mean, I love forests. But I love other ecosystems too. This is a forest scientist named Forest, Forest Flashtman.
是的，我的意思是，万亿棵树论文所犯的一个大错误是，他们某种程度上说，没有树的区域没有碳。这不是真的，因为没有树的区域地下有碳。不仅是泥炭地，健康的草原也将碳储存在地下。因此，我们不应该只考虑我们可以种多少树，而应该考虑所有不同的方法，在不牺牲生物多样性的情况下，最大限度地提高任何给定景观中的碳储存。这可能意味着恢复泥炭地或保护健康的草原和森林，这也可能
Yeah, so I mean, one of the big mistakes that the trillion tree paper made is they sort of said, well, areas without trees don't have carbon. And that's not true because areas without trees have carbon below ground. And not just petlands, healthy grasslands also store carbon underground. So instead of just thinking about how many trees we can plant, we should be thinking about all the different ways we can maximize carbon storage in any given landscape without sacrificing biodiversity. That might mean restoring petlands or protecting healthy grasslands and forests, and it might
意味着种植更多的树木。如果种树对一个景观来说是正确的事情，我们将不得不做的不仅仅是种植它们。福莱施曼研究了为应对气候变化而进行的植树造林努力，他发现它们往往会失败，因为所有的注意力都集中在让树苗入土的最初行动上。
mean planting more trees. And if planting trees is the right thing for a landscape, we're gonna have to do more than just plant them. Forest Flitechman has studied tree planting efforts that are being done for climate change, and he's found that often they fail because all of the focus is on that initial act of getting the saplings in the ground.
因为这是政客可以走进去做的事情，拍一张照片，登上报纸头版或电视。但在接下来的几年里，这些树往往会被人砍倒、被牛吃掉或在火灾中烧毁。所以这段对话说，哦，我们需要种植一万亿棵树。好吧，实际上，我们不需要种植一万亿棵树。假设种植一万亿棵树是正确的。我们需要确保一万亿棵树能够生长。
Because it's something that a politician can walk in and do and get a picture taken and be on the front page of the newspaper or beyond TV. But then often in the years that follow, those trees get cut down by people or eaten by cows or burned in a fire. So this dialogue says, oh, we need to plant a trillion trees. Well actually, we don't need to plan to truly entree. Let's say the truly entree is right. We need to make sure that a truly entree is grow.
确保树木生长比种植它们更复杂。弗莱施曼说，第一步是停止砍伐我们剩下的健康森林。我们需要停止非法砍伐，抵制那些推迟森林砍伐的公司，并努力保护土著人民的权利，他们通常是森林最好的保护者。在我们种植新林的地方，我们需要与当地人合作，确保他们从新树中受益，并投入到让它们不断生长中。所以当我们开始这样思考时，它真正变成了一个政治和经济问题，而不是一个技术性的植树问题。
And making sure that trees grow is more complicated than planting them. Fleischmann says the first step is to stop cutting down the healthy forests that we have left. We need to stop illegal logging and boycott the companies that are driving before a station and work to protect the rights of indigenous people who are often the best protectors of forests. And where we do plant new forests, we need to work with local people to make sure that they benefit from the new trees and are invested in keeping them growing. So when we start thinking about it this way, it really becomes a political and economic problem, not a technical tree planting problem.
我认为人们对植树感到非常兴奋，部分原因是因为它是一个似乎存在于政治和经济之外的解决方案。这是一个简单的、自然的解决方案，不需要我们通过大规模的立法或建立一个全新的能源系统。但事实是，气候变化从根本上说是一个复杂的、政治的、经济的和技术的完美问题。没有单一的完美解决方案。但我们无论如何都需要解决它。沼泽是最棒的。在此之后，我们还有更多关于沼泽的酷炫事实。所以埃mett回来了，我们要谈谈沼泽。
I think that people get really excited about tree planting in part because it's a solution that seems to exist outside of politics and economics. It's this simple, natural solution that doesn't require us to pass massive legislation or build a whole new energy system. But the truth is that climate change is fundamentally a complicated, political, and economic and technological problem. There is no one perfect solution. But we need to solve it anyway. Bugs are the best. We have so many more cool facts about Bugs after this. So Emmett is back and we're going to talk about Bugs.
是的，所以了解关于沼泽的所有事情时，我发现有趣的事情之一就是围绕它们的所有语言。你知道，你有那么多不同的词来形容沼泽。沼泽（Bog）、沼泽（Fen）、沼泽（Mire）、沼泽（Moore）、沼泽（Marsh）、沼泽（Swamp）、沼泽（Puckison）。这是梅丽特 · 图雷茨基，又是我们故事中的泥炭女王。她说，你知道，这些不一定是同义词。所有这些不同的词之间都有细微的差别。其中一些植根于生态学和湿地分类。
Yeah, so one of the things that I found interesting learning all about Bugs was all the language around them. You know, you've got so many different words for Bugs. Bugs, Fenn, Meyer, Moore, Marsh, Swamp, Puckison. This is Merit Turetsky, again, the queen of Pete from our story. And she says that, you know, these aren't synonyms necessarily. There are subtle differences between all these different words. Some of them are rooted in ecology and wetland classification.
其中一些是地域性的。但沼泽语言、湿地分类中也存在着这种整个隐喻的一面，其中一些是地域性的。但沼泽语言、湿地语言也存在着这种整个隐喻的一面。就像我们经常使用很多这些词一样，实际上，不是以泥炭地科学的方式，而是以这种更具诗意的隐喻意义。通常沼泽语言意味着陷入困境。对，就像陷入某事中一样，对吧。
Some of them are regional. But there's also this whole sort of metaphorical side to bog language, wetland classification, some of them are regional. But there's also this whole sort of metaphorical side to bog language, wetland language. Like we use a lot of these words a lot, actually, not in a Pete Lynn science way, but in this kind of more poetic metaphorical sense. And usually bog language connotes stuckness. Right, like getting bogged down in something, yeah.
对，没错。但还有很多其他的例子，比如泥潭（Quagmire）好吧，对吧？一种沼泽。你可以陷入泥潭，Mire 是一种沼泽，或者实际上我认为 Bog 是一种 Mire，这就像一个正方形和长方形的情况。沼泽（Morass）是另一种用来形容有点泥泞的沼泽湿地的词，但它也像一个
Right, exactly. But there's a lot of other examples like a quagmire Well, right? type of bog And you can get you can get my or something a my or is a type of bog or actually I think a bog is a type of My or it's like a square rectangle situation A morass is another word for kind of marshy boggy wetland but also like a
可能会让你陷入其中的混乱局面。那么，为什么大多数人可能并不经常接触沼泽，我们却如此频繁地使用这些词，这有什么解释呢？你知道，我认为对梅丽特 · 图雷茨基来说，她说这就好像尽管沼泽是我们不一定会花很多时间的地方，但人类一直对它们着迷，它们一直代表着这种几乎是超自然的中间空间。
confusing situation that you might get stuck in. So what is the explanation for why we use these words so much when most people probably don't experience bogs on a really regular basis? You know, I think that for merit-trki, she says that it's like even though bogs are these places that we don't necessarily spend a lot of time, we've always, humans have always been fascinated by them and they've always represented this like almost supernatural in-between space.
我认为由于这种神秘感，不是陆地，不是水，不是完全活着，也不是完全死去，它们对我们来说真的很迷人。因此，电影、流行文化、文学中的沼泽通常代表人们可以向社会隐藏的地方，或者你可能会迷路的地方。这在书本和电影中完全真实。我记得在《呼啸山庄》中，你知道，你有荒原，它们在整本书中通常
And I think because of the mysteriousness of that, not being land, not being water, not being fully alive, not being fully dead, they're really fascinating to us. And so, bogs in movies, in pop culture, in literature often represent a place where people can hide from society or where you can potentially get lost. And this is totally true in books and movies. I remember in Withering Heights, you know, you have the Moors, which are often
呈现为这种不祥的景观，卡瑟琳和希刺克利夫可能会在那里迷路或溺水。或者在《指环王》中，他们穿过这些充满了盯着他们的死人面孔的沼泽。有死物。
are presented throughout the book as this kind of foreboding landscape where they might, you know, catheter and heatcliff might get lost or drowned. Or in Lord of the Rings, they sort of wind their way through these marshes that are filled with dead faces looking up at them. There are dead things.
水里的死面孔。当我还是个孩子的时候，真正震撼我的是《大地的传说》中的悲伤之沼，你知道，他的马实际上在里面陷下去了。这太悲惨了，太令人不安了。是的，完全是。我差点剪辑了那段视频，但听着这个小男孩为他溺水的马尖叫，感觉
Dead faces in the water. When I was a kid, the one that really got me was the swamp of sadness and the never-ending story, you know, where his horse actually gets swelled up in it. It's just so tragic, so upsetting. Yeah, totally. I almost pulled a clip from that, but it was like too kind of unpleasant
太不愉快了。非常悲伤。真正浮现在我脑海中的是《公主新娘》。你知道，角色们正在穿过或在火之沼泽中导航，你知道，火焰从土壤中喷涌而出，他们必须躲避这些危险。我的意思是，火之沼泽的三大恐怖是什么？
to listen to this little boy screaming about his drowning horse. It's very sad. The one that really comes to mind for me is the Princess Bride. You know, the characters are traversing or navigating their way through a fire swamp, where, you know, bursts of flames come up through the soil and they have to dodge these hazards. I mean, what are the three terrors of the fire swamp?
第一，火焰喷发。没问题。每次爆发前都会有爆裂声，避开那个。第二，流沙，但你足够聪明，能发现它长什么样。所以将来，我们也可以避开那个。贝斯利，那 R.R.U.S. 呢？
One, the flamespot. No problem. There's a popping sound proceeding each week and avoid that. Two, the lightning sand, but you will clever enough to discover what that looks like. So in the future, we can avoid that, too. Bessley, what about the RRUSs?
体型异常的啮齿动物？我不认为它们存在。啊！是的，你怎么能忘记体型异常的啮齿动物呢？对。你知道，R.A.U.S. 显然并不真的存在，但图雷茨基说，火之沼泽的某些方面并没有你想象的那么牵强。
Rodents of unusual size? I don't think they exist. Ah! Yeah, how could you forget the rodent of unusual size? Right. And, you know, the R.A. U.S. is obviously don't really exist, but Tresky says that some aspects of the fire swamp aren't quite as far fetched as you might imagine.
䐁全圣地道外均不大其
There are gases, some of them are flammable that are produced in these very wet saturated bog systems. We don't often see flames leaping up through a bog system, but there is a lot of methane produced because of this really anaerobic decomposition. And that methane actually could be flammable. I mean, that is shocking that that could be based on any kind of reality. I mean, come to think of it, the dead people in the bogs like the Lord of the Rings, that is shocking that that could be based in any kind of reality. I mean, come to think of it, you know, the dead people in the bogs like the Lord of the Rings, that also feels like a reference to the bog people that we touch on in the main body of the
有些沼泽系统非常湿润饱和，其中会产生一些气体，其中一些是易燃的。我们不常看到火焰在沼泽系统中窜起，但因为这种真正的厌氧分解，会产生大量的甲烷。而这些甲烷实际上可能是易燃的。我的意思是，这太让人震惊了，这竟然有可能是基于任何现实情况。我的意思是，仔细想想，沼泽里的死者就像《指环王》里那样，这太让人震惊了，这竟然有可能是基于任何现实情况。我的意思是，仔细想想，你知道的，沼泽里的死者就像《指环王》里那样，这感觉也像是在致敬我们在正文中提到的沼泽人
episode. Right. Bog bodies. Yeah. And so, you know, in general, I think bogs are portrayed as these kind of dark, scary places as we've zoned throughout this. And like usually there is some truth to that. Like they are hard to walk through and you can get stuck in the mud. And there are weird gases. So it's like, it's like a caricature based in some amount of real, real accurate details of what it's like. But it also falls really short and fully appreciating them
插曲。没错。沼泽尸体。是的。所以，你知道的，总的来说，我认为沼泽被描绘成那种黑暗、可怕的地方，正如我们在整个过程中所指出的那样。通常这也有一定的道理。比如它们很难走过去，你可能会陷入泥潭。而且还有奇怪的气体。所以这就像是一个以某种程度真实、准确的细节为基础的夸张形象，描绘了它是什么样的。但它也远远没有真正充分欣赏它们
for the incredible places that they are. Yeah, so I have to admit, bugs are like my favorite ecosystem. I think they're so cool. I used to study botany in the Midwest. There's much more bugs. There's no bugs here in the really in the West Coast to speak up,
作为不可思议的地方。是的，所以我必须承认，沼泽就像我最喜欢的生态系统。我觉得它们太酷了。我以前在中西部研究植物学。那里有更多的沼泽。西海岸这里真的没有什么沼泽可言，
but there's real bugs there. I like a cranberry bog. I like a quaking bog. I mean, a quaking bog is like with a spagnum grows so thick that trees can grow on it. If you get enough people, they can jump on the spagnum and trees can sway from you jumping on the ground. It is like, bugs are amazing. I love them.
但那里有真正的沼泽。我喜欢蔓越莓沼泽。我喜欢颤根沼泽。我的意思是，颤根沼泽就像是泥炭藓长得那么厚，树木甚至可以在上面生长。如果你有足够多的人，他们可以在泥炭藓上跳跃，树木会随着你跳在地上而摇晃。这就像，沼泽太神奇了。我爱死它们了。
Yeah. I wanted to pitch this story because I wanted to go to Scotland and check out these bugs. I also think bogs. I'm so sorry. And then that immediately became an impossibility with the COVID situation. But can I share one cool bog fact that I didn't get to work into the story?
是的。我想做这个故事，因为我想去苏格兰看看这些沼泽。我也觉得沼泽。非常抱歉。然后随着新冠疫情的情况，这立即成为了不可能的事情。不过，我可以分享一个我没能写进故事里的很酷的沼泽冷知识吗？
Absolutely, go for it. So did you know that bogs breathe? No, I did not know that. So there's this, yeah, there's this common phenomenon in Peteland science called bog breathing. And what we mean by that is that the surface of a bog, the surface of the vegetation layer moves up and down. It expands or it shrinks depending on the hydrology
当然，说吧。你知道沼泽会呼吸吗？不，我不知道。所以，有一个，是的，在泥炭地科学中有一个常见的现象叫做沼泽呼吸。我们的意思是，沼泽的表面，植被层的表面会上下移动。根据水文情况，它会膨胀或收缩
and where the water table is sitting. And this is actually an adaptive trait. It means when conditions are wet, the water table adjusts and the whole peat layer adjusts to that shift when things get dry. Again, that peat layer responds. So it's not really breathing that's in like respiration. It's more like a metaphor of movement
以及潜水面所处的位置。这实际上是一个适应性特征。这意味着当条件湿润时，潜水面会调整，整个泥炭层也会适应这种变化；当情况变干时，泥炭层也会做出反应。所以它并不是真正意义上的呼吸，就像呼吸作用那样。与其说是呼吸，不如说它是运动的一个比喻
when they say bog breathing. Yeah, yeah, it's almost like, I like to think of it as like, the bog is like a, like a giant's belly that's like rising and falling as the ecosystem sort of breathes in and out. But it takes on more space and kind of pushes up to the sky.
当他们说沼泽呼吸时。对，对，这几乎就像，我喜欢把它想象成，沼泽就像一个巨人的肚子，随着生态系统的呼吸而起伏。但它占据了更多的空间，并有点向上推向天空。
Almost like your diaphragm would expand when you're taking a deep breath, but then that can also contract down and that breath is then expelled. And you know, this isn't a new phenomenon like scientists have known about bog breathing for a really long time, but it's incredibly difficult to measure. So this is Roxanne Anderson again. So if you think about it, trying to go and measure how much the surface moves up and down, and that's in the order of millimeters,
几乎就像你的横膈膜在深呼吸时会膨胀，但随后它也会收缩，然后把那口气呼出来。你知道的，这并不是什么新鲜现象，科学家们知道沼泽呼吸已经有很长时间了，但它极其难以测量。所以这是罗克珊·安德森再次说的。因此，如果你仔细想想，试图去测量表面上下移动了多少，而且那是在毫米的量级上，
if you try to measure that by walking onto the bog, which is an unstable and wobbly surface, it's gonna be very difficult. Right, it's like trying to measure the surface of a water bath. You know, it constantly moves underneath your feet. That must be really frustrating if you're trying to measure it. Yeah, exactly.
如果你试图通过步行走到沼泽上来测量，那是一个不稳定且晃动的表面，这将是非常困难的。没错，这就像试图测量水面的表面。你知道的，它在你脚下不断移动。如果你试图测量它，那一定真的很沮丧。是的，完全如此。
And so Roxanne Anderson and her colleagues have been looking at ways that they could measure this without actually going out and trying to measure this surface manually. And what we've been looking at is using satellites that uses radar. So basically using radar from a satellite to send a signal down to
所以罗克珊·安德森和她的同事们一直在寻找方法，可以不用亲自出去手动测量这个表面就能测量它。我们一直在研究的是使用使用雷达的卫星。基本上就是利用来自卫星的雷达向
the bog every few days and getting measurements on how that surface level is changing over time. What Roxanne and her colleagues have been trying to figure out is, can they use that bog breathing pattern from the satellite data as an indicator of the overall health of the Peteland? It's like a doctor putting a stethoscope to your back and saying deep breath. Right, right, exactly, exactly. And I think gathering that data could help scientists understand whether a Peteland is functioning as a healthy Peteland and a robust carbon sink or whether it's degraded
每隔几天向沼泽发送一次信号，并获得关于该表面水平随时间变化的测量结果。罗克珊和她的同事们一直试图弄清楚的是，他们能否利用来自卫星数据的这种沼泽呼吸模式作为泥炭地整体健康的指标？这就像医生把听诊器贴在你的背上说深呼吸。对，对，完全如此，完全如此。而且我认为收集这些数据可以帮助科学家了解泥炭地是否作为一个健康的泥炭地和强大的碳汇在发挥作用，或者它是否已经退化
in some way that you maybe didn't know and might be actually emitting carbon. So what's the pattern they're finding? And like, how do you tell if the breathing of a bog is healthy or not? Yeah, I asked Roxanne that. So what we've found is that kind of healthy peat learned, if you like, to have one peak in one trough, roughly every year, and the peak is usually, if they're really healthy,
以某种你可能不知道的方式，甚至可能实际上在排放碳。那么他们发现的模式是什么？以及，你如何判断沼泽的呼吸是否健康？是的，我问过罗克珊。所以我们发现的是，健康的泥炭地，如果你喜欢的话，每年大约有一个峰和一个谷，如果它们真的很健康，峰通常
it's usually gonna be in the autumn, with quite a high amplitude, and then the trough is gonna be in the spring. So you have this kind of cycle of peaks and trough. So one big breath in and one big breath out every year? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then the more degree that it gets, the more it just becomes kind of no peaks, no troughs, just kind of a flatter line. Well, you don't want to see a flat line like an EKG, you don't want that.
通常会在秋天出现，具有相当大的振幅，然后谷会在春天出现。所以你会有这种峰谷的循环。也就是每年吸一大口气，呼一大口气？对，对，对，对。然后退化的程度越高，它就越变成没有峰，没有谷，只是一种更平坦的线。好吧，你可不想看到像心电图那样的平坦直线，你可不想那样。
Right, right. And you know, Roxanne says that this new way of gathering bog breathing data is actually like really important or could be really, really important for Petelyn conservation globally. I think that the interesting thing for me about this is that it completely changes the way that we can understand Petelyn globally
对，对。而且你知道，罗克珊说，这种收集沼泽呼吸数据的新方法实际上非常重要，或者对于全球泥炭地保护来说可能非常非常重要。我认为这件事对我来说有趣的地方在于，它完全改变了我们理解全球泥炭地的方式
because we can just do that, you know, if we spend the time to do the validation like we've done here for any type of people, and you might end up with knowing what the signal or the breathing pattern for a particular type of people is, and you might be able to detect anomalies that are diagnostic of degradation for people that are impossible to reach, are very degradation for beatlands that, you know, that are impossible to reach or
因为我们只需要这样做，你知道的，如果我们花时间像我们在这里为任何类型的泥炭地所做的那样进行验证，你最终可能会了解特定类型泥炭地的信号或呼吸模式，并且你可能会发现对于那些不可能到达或者很难到达的泥炭地退化具有诊断意义的异常现象，对于那些不可能到达或
very, very difficult to reach that really remote or impossible to visit on a regular basis. And this is really important because like, you know, so many beatlands are in these remote locations and they're their places that humans have tended to avoid. And we're actually still discovering new beatlands, and often they're really hard to access. And we're actually still discovering new petlins. And often they're really hard to access. And so it could be this really helpful tool in mapping and understanding the role that petlins are playing as carbon sinks
非常、非常难以到达、真正偏远或不可能定期访问的泥炭地退化。这非常重要，因为你知道的，这么多的泥炭地都在这些偏远的位置，它们是人类往往会避开的地方。而且我们实际上仍在发现新的泥炭地，通常它们真的很难接近。而且我们实际上仍在发现新的泥炭地。通常它们真的很难接近。所以这可能是一个非常有用工具，用于绘制地图并理解泥炭地所扮演的角色，是作为碳汇
or as carbon sources. Mm-hmm. I mean, one of the things that I think is really interesting about the story is that the petlins are doing a lot of good if they're healthy, but if they're not healthy, they're actually kind of a problem because they release that carbon that they've stored.
还是作为碳源。嗯。我的意思是，我认为关于这个故事非常有趣的事情之一是，如果泥炭地是健康的，它们在做很多好事，但如果它们不健康，它们实际上有点像是个问题，因为它们会释放出它们储存的碳。
Right, exactly. It's super important that we find out where they are and monitor them and really are invested in keeping them healthy all around the world. Like it's like all of our well-being is sort of caught up in that carbon beneath these hot spots all over the world. Yeah, oh, it's so cool. Well, I love Bogs even more now. Thank you so much, Emmett.
对，完全如此。我们找出它们在哪里并监测它们，并且真正投入精力让它们在世界各地保持健康，这是超级重要的。就像我们所有人的福祉都与世界各地这些热点底部的碳息息相关。是的，哦，太酷了。好吧，现在我更喜欢沼泽了。非常感谢你，埃梅特。
Yeah, of course. This classic episode of 99PI was produced by Emmett Fitzgerald and mixed by Bryson Barnes. Tech Productions on this update by Martin Gonzalez and Jacob Maldonado Medina. Music by Swan Rihall. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kirk Colstad is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, Jason DeLeon, Joe Rosenberg, Intern Sarah Baker,
好的，当然。这集经典的 99PI 由埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德制作，布莱森·巴恩斯混音。马丁·冈萨雷斯和雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳对本更新进行了技术制作。音乐由斯旺·里霍尔创作。德兰尼·霍尔是执行制片人，柯克·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢马顿、索菲娅·克拉茨克、杰森·德莱昂、乔·罗森伯格、实习生萨拉·贝克，
and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Jesse Reynolds of UCLA, who we spoke to for the story, and also writers for Virginia Guin and Sharon Levy whose articles about flow country got us interested in the region. For more articles about Pete Lindt restoration in Scotland, we will have links on the website. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now head
还有我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢我们为这个故事采访过的加州大学洛杉矶分校的杰西·雷诺兹，还要感谢弗吉尼亚·吉恩和莎朗·利维的撰稿人，他们关于流之乡的文章让我们对这个地区产生了兴趣。有关苏格兰泥炭地恢复的更多文章，我们将在网站上提供链接。99% 可见是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分。现在前往
cord six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Or on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to their stature shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. dot org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
潘多拉大厦向北走六个街区。在美丽的。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我 @Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI org。或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。您可以在 99PI 点 org 上找到我喜欢的事斯奇特节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集过往节目。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。